I was brought up in the Betty Crocker era.
You had to get married and you had to have a child.
That's what it was about, to meet the guy,...
...to get married, to have babies, to be the president of the PTA.
Every place I went for interviews,...
...the only thing they wanted to know was, "Can you type?"
Your high score on the Scholastic Aptitude Test...
...indicates that you can become a good secretary.
It was as if a great floodlight had gone on and it illuminated everything.
We were so idealistic, we were so energetic, we were so in-your-face...
...and there were so many of us!
We had to change the system.
Everything in the workplace, everything in the political sphere,...
...everything in the domestic sphere.
What we are talking about is a revolution and not a reform.
It was exhilarating!
It was also somewhat torturing because we were breaking new ground.
Our message was "Family!"
Appreciate the woman, appreciate the mother...
...and her role in developing the next generation.
Somehow you end up doing all the laundry and 90 percent of the grocery shopping.
We need to live in a world where men do half, women let them do half...
...and being a parent is not a full-time job for a woman and a part-time job for a man.
What women were looking for is not that guarantee that they would succeed...
...but at least the opportunity to try.